ja eine lage die wir mit karl lauterbach
besprechen wollen guten abend nach köln
hallo guten abend erlaubt aber wenn wir
uns einen hauch hoffnung einflößen
wollten was muss jetzt passieren aus
ihrer sicht um die wucht der vierten
welle doch noch zu brechen oder ist es
dafür längst zu spät
wir werden die vierte wäre brechen
allerdings wir müssen die booster
impfung massiv beschleunigen ist
wirklich sehr schnell geimpft werden wir
müssen die kontakt beschränkungen viel
besser kontrollieren also zweig und 2g
plus muss kontrolliert werden also es
muss auch zu entsprechenden sanktionen
kommen und wie werden die kontakte aus
werten also werden wir die kontakte
nicht stärker runter bekommen als sie es
bisher sehen wird man möglicherweise
auch noch einmal nach schärfen müssen
ihre parteichefin saskia esken setzt ja
auch auf booster sie setzt auf zweig und
2g plus und auch kontakt beschränkungen
wie sie sagen aber frau es gehen will
keinen lockdown für geimpfte gehen sie
damit
naja ob wir nochmal einen login für
geimpfte brauchen das bezweifle ich auch
denn also welchen sinn hätte die impfung
wenn man dann doch in den lock down muss
sehr viel entscheidender ist dass wir
diejenigen jetzt erreichen die noch
ungeimpft sind sehr in gent ist auch
dass diejenigen nochmal empfinde ich
schon geimpft sind die booster impfungen
und wir müssen schauen dass wir die
großen veranstaltung runter bekommen
denn die sind tatsächlich für die
infektion von bedeutung also hier kann
man also wahrscheinlich also noch andere
nach schaffen aber wir haben gute
beschlüsse gefasst wir sehen auch schon
wirkung die wirkung ist aber nicht so
stark wie also notwendig es muss
möglicherweise noch einmal nachgelegt
die ampel parteien die wollen aber nicht
nachlegen die wollen jetzt erstmal das
infektionsgeschehen zehn tage beobachten
zumindest sagt das annalena baerbock
sehen ob und wie booster impfungen und
die neuen maßnahmen an schlagen haben
wir dann in der jetzigen lage wirklich
so viel zeit
also jetzt die lage zu beobachten das
ist natürlich notwendig weil die also
maßnahmen die wirken der seit ein paar
tagen aber man muss jeden tag schauen
das machen wir ja auch also die daten
werden noch tagesaktuell erhoben jeden
tag bekommen wir neue bewegungsprofile
beispielsweise und somit also können wir
das schon einschätzen die antwort das
gut lösen also wir sind dann täglichen
austausch übrigens auch mit der noch
amtierenden regierung
zb bin ich auch ein austausch mit jens
spahn und mit so mit anderen also wir
sind im guten austausch wir kriegen das
problem in den griff aber es ist
schwerer als gedacht wir sind dann noch
zu spät eingestiegen und sind ein paar
wochen verloren gegangen wo wir früher
mit 2g und 2g plus schon etwa viren
müssen immerhin zieht ja die
impfkampagne jetzt deutlich an aber die
hausärzte die bekommen nächste woche
wohl nur die hälfte der bestellten
impfstoffe zum teil weniger als die
eigentlich garantierten 30 dosen pro
woche wird die wachsende
impfbereitschaft so nicht gleich wieder
abgewürgt
dieses problem muss auch gelöst wenn ihr
sagen wir die gute nachricht dass
moderner der impfstoff der genauso gut
ist wie bei antec also in kaum
begrenzter zahl zur verfügung steht das
heißt also hier kann jeder geimpft
werden da gibt werden möchte wenn auch
moderat ist moderner zu nehmen diesen
sehr sehr guten dem stoff und zum
zweiten also wenn tatsächlich hier also
etwas weniger biontech 8 zur verfügung
steht dann liegt das auch daran dass
gott sei dank die zahl der ärzte die
impfen wollen viel größer ist als
berechnet wurde also das
bundesgesundheitsministerium hat ja
diese 30.000 pro arzt berechnet und
jetzt sind aber sehr viel mehr ärzte
bereit zu impfen das eine gute nachricht
sagt der spd gesundheitsexperte karl
lauterbach
ob hier auch der neue
bundesgesundheitsminister gesprochen hat
die frage können wir heute abend leider
nicht klären vielen dank noch köln
ich danke ihnen und es gibt